if I asked you to picture the air what
do you imagine most people think about
either empty space or clear blue sky or
sometimes trees dancing in the wind and
then I remember my high school chemistry
teacher with really long socks at the
blackboard drawing diagrams are sort of
bubbles connected to other bubbles and
describing how they vibrate and collide
in a kind of frantic suit but really we
tend not to think about the air that
much at all we notice that mostly when
there's some kind of unpleasant sensory
intrusion upon it like a terrible smell
or something visible like smoke or mist
but it's always there it's touching all
of us right now it's even inside us our
air is immediate vital and intimate and
yet it's so easily forgotten so what is
the air it's the combination of the
invisible gases that envelop the earth
attracted by the Earth's gravitational
pull and even though I'm a visual artist
I'm interested in the invisibility of
the air I'm interested in how we
imagined it how we experience it and how
we all have an innate understanding of
its materiality through breathing all
life on Earth changes the air through
gas exchange and we're all doing it
right now
and actually why don't we all right now
together take one big collective deep
breath in ready
in and out
[Applause]
so that air that you just exhale you
enrich a hundred times in carbon dioxide
so roughly five liters of air per breast
17 breaths per minute of the 525,600
minutes per you comes to approximately
45 million liters of air enriched
hundred times in carbon dioxide just for
you
now let's equivalent to about 18 Olympic
sized swimming pools for me air is
plural
it's similarly as small as our breathing
and as big as the planet and it's kind
of hard to picture
maybe it's impossible and maybe it
doesn't matter so through my visual arts
practice I try to make a not so much
picture it but to make it visceral and
tactile and haptic I try to expand this
motion of the aesthetic how things look
so that it can include things like how
it feels on your skin and in your lungs
and how your voice sounds as it passes
through it I explore the weight density
and smell but most importantly I think a
lot about the stories that we attach to
different kinds of air so this is a work
that I made in 2014 and it's called
different kinds of air appliance diary
where I was recreating the air from
different eras in Earth evolution and
inviting the audience to come in and
breed them with me and it's really
surprising so drastically different now
I'm not a scientist but atmospheric
scientists will look for traces in the
air chemistry in geology a bit like how
rocks can oxidize and they will
extrapolate that information and
aggregate it such that they can pretty
much form a recipe for the air at
different times then I come in as the
artist
take that recipe and recreate it using
two component gases I was particularly
interested in moments of time that are
examples of life changing the air but
also the air that can influence how life
will evolve like Carboniferous air so
it's from about 300 to 350 million years
ago it's an era known as the time of the
giants so for the first time in the
history of life lignin evolves now
that's the hard stuff that trees are
made of the trees effectively invent
their own trunks at this time and they
get really big bigger and bigger and
fatter the earth releasing oxygen
releasing oxygen releasing oxygen such
that the oxygen levels are about twice
as high as what they are today and this
rich air supports kind of massive
insects so huge spiders and dragonflies
with a wingspan of about 65 centimeters
to breathe this air is really clean and
really fresh it doesn't so much have a
flavor but it does give your body a
really subtle kind of boost of energy
it's really good for hangovers although
the air of the great dying so that's
about 250 2.5 million years ago just
before the dinosaurs evolved and it's a
really short time period geologically
speaking from about 20 to 200 thousand
years really quick this is the greatest
extinction event in Earth history even
bigger than when the dinosaurs died out
85 to 95 percent of species at this time
died out and simultaneous to that it's a
huge dramatic spike in carbon dioxide
that a lot of scientists agree come from
a similar eruption of volcanoes and a
runaway greenhouse effect oxygen levels
at this time go to below half what they
are today so about 10% so this air was
definitely not support human life but
it's okay to just have a breath and to
breathe it's oddly comforting it's
really calming it's quite
warm and it has a flavor a little bit
like like soda water has that kind of
spritz quite pleasant so with all this
thinking about air of the past it's
quite natural to start thinking about
the air of the future and instead of
being speculative with air and just
making out what I think might be the
future air I discovered this human
synthesized air so that means that it
doesn't occur anywhere in nature but
it's made by humans in a laboratory for
application in different industrial
settings why is it future air well this
air is a really stable molecule that
will literally be part of the air once
it's released for the next 300 to 400
years before it's broken down so that's
around about 12 to 16 generations and
this future air has some very sensual
qualities it's very heavy it's about
eight times heavier than the air that
we're used to breathing it's so heavy in
fact that when you breathe it in
whatever words you speak are kind of
literally heavy as well so they dribble
down your chin and drop to the floor and
soak into the cracks so it's an air that
operates quite a lot like a liquid now
this air comes with an ethical dimension
as well humans made this air but it's
also the most potent greenhouse gas that
has ever been tested its warming
potential is twenty four thousand times
that of carbon dioxide and it has that
longevity of 12 to 16 generations
so this epical confrontation is really
central to my work
but I have another quite supposin
quarter it changes some of your work
quite dramatically so when we start to
think all the spillover when we think
about climate change we probably don't
think about giant insects and erupting
volcanoes or funny voices the images
that more readily come to mind are
things like retreating glaciers and
polar bears adrift on icebergs we think
about pie charts and column graphs and
endless politicians talking to
scientists wearing cardigans but perhaps
it's time that we start thinking about
climate change on the same visceral
level that we experience the air like
air climate change is similar Aeneas Lee
at the scale of the molecule the breast
and the planet its immediate vital and
intimate as well as being a morphus and
cumbersome and yet it's so easily
forgotten climate change is the
collective self-portrait of humanity it
reflects our decisions as individuals as
governments and as industries and if
there's anything that I've learned from
looking at air it's that even though
it's changing it persists it may not
support the kind of life that we'd
recognize but it will support something
and if we humans are such a vital part
of that change I think it's important
that we can feel this discussion because
even though it's invisible
humans are leaving a very vibrant trace
in the air thank you
[Applause]